et y le jeu de société auquel on joue
comporte beaucoup de vulgarité d'humour
noir donc si vous êtes très sensible et
balle et jouer a dit bout du monde c'est
quand on a notre incroyable intro
aujourd'hui on se retrouve pour jouer
aux jeux de société blanc-manger coco
qu'aux blancs et moi j'étais au chlore
le principe du jeu est très simple j'ai
devant moi des cartes qui contiennent
des mots est tout aussi des réponses on
va dire qu'on me dise expression d
expression est devant nous et je t'ai
donné ta phrase ça va non ce qu'on va
régler ça va il dénonce aval très
bizarre est devant nous un paquet de
cartes noires qui contiennent des
phrases à compléter avec les mots qu'on
a devant nous dans nos paquets
respectifs voilà je faisais rien compris
vous allez comprendre qu est celui qui
est le plus drôle marque un fond
exactement et tu gagnes quand tu as cinq
fois ça s'est tellement ton père
m'habite c'est tellement tendue moi
j'avais les grands donateurs de la
banque du sperme ça c'est mon
habitat qui gagne c'est dur là-bas le
fait d'avoir placé juste ma [ __ ]
m'habite tellement ton père a l'air
moins pour l'udc et un char malgré les
annonces du coup j'ai pu voir utiliser
m'habite c'est toi c'est bien c'est bien
c'est mieux donc là il faut deux cartes
moi c'est pas spécialement drôle ouais
mais des deux thèmes vont ensemble
d'accords donc il a brillé mais a
tellement sale année un regard une ak-47
c'est bien l'industrie de l'armement
c'est bien
c'est pas drôle
coucher le premier soir c'est bien violé
une chèvre c'est mieux
et hôtels suit la lémance tel gène x gen
juin ce qui distingue l'homme de
l'animal à mon sens c'est au ce qui
distingue l'homme de l'animal à mon sens
c'est ma chatte bien sûr la marque à la
jeanne
mordoj ans la mienne tu as fait rire
personne à part ce skateboard ce qui
distingue l'homme de l'animal à mon sens
c'était beau l'art voilà tu as gagné ce
week end si on se penche sur les
statistiques et sont étroitement
corrélés si on se penche sur les
statistiques
malgré l'atonie vieillard un stress et
au jeu moi je pense que c'est pas drôle
si on se penche sur les statistiques
un samedi soir devant le plus grand
cabaret du monde et la gueule de bois
sont étroitement qui aurait des corps et
des
[Musique]
émetteurs qui sont pas drôles aa si on
se penche sur les statistiques
un cancer de la prostate et une crise
hémorroïdaire sont étroitement corrélés
c'est pas très drôle très drôle mais
c'est un beau mais un bon ami comme tu
restes dans le domaine médical à un
apéro son pastis et pourquoi pas de san
antonio alors là j'ai un perfect
derrière un nom il ya no 1 brian haw
abonnez-vous à sa chaîne comme ça les
imiter il veut pas dire du tout un apéro
sans pastis et pourquoi pas changer de
femme pour monter en gamme
sans un boxeur sans un boxeur porté huit
jours de suite un apéro son pastis et
pourquoi pas la double pénétration sans
une erreur de diagnostic
bon centre au vih
allez l'a41 paul luckham au chat c'est
qu'il est connu mais qui s'appelait
johan 4 ans entre une vie de famille il
faut choisir entre allumer le feu et
huit familles il faut choisir johnny
hallyday la passion
entre ségolène valérie et julie et une
vie de famille il veut bien aller 5-1
j'ai gagné à l'énoncé de bongo
magical corps comme l'a révélé qu'au
corps deuxième manche mais comme j'ai
pas eu de chance au tirage je propose
qu'on ait le même sac et on tire en
sommes aussi bien les questions que les
réponses aux îles avant des règles ça me
plait ya raté la naissance de son fils
pour le sperme qui collent sur la
baignoire harrington a
raté la naissance de son fils pour un
diabolo grenadine à la rigueur qui
s'offusquent
j'ai
faim justifie la vague bleue marine
je suis très drôle la fin justifie
l'apec hop je m'arrete points quand il
ya égalité round round 2 justifie le
point g o n est pas l a indiqué du cul
de sac plein moi j'adore un bel dans les
fesses jetant récent et était un des 2 0
à la fin justifie le botox j'ai gagné
ouais le projet c'était du gilenia la
vraie raison des premiers cheveux blancs
c'est le connard qui ne recule jamais
les chiottes
un vrai long des premiers cheveux blancs
c'est une pause gourmande
[Rires]
4 1 pour yam johann hay al yah johann
hay à 24,1 et la ba oui c'est mayoral
afin de pimenter notre vie de couple a
fait 35 ans de mariage mais pratiquement
tout cas une fausse promesse de dons au
téléthon
pas drôle afin de pimenter votre vie de
couple après 35 ans mariage ne
pratiquons pas drake ça va
l'original
ou comment allier l'utile à l'agréable
au
caca mou du lendemain de soirée et un
toucher rectal ou comment allier l'utile
à l'agréable
pas mal sept ans sans sexe et un doigt
dans le cul
des éléphanteaux elles marchent avec
nous là j'en crois une opinion un bain
dans le cul c'est comme une bonne guerre
ça forge la jeunesse
d'avaler tout a donc eu le film
il veut pas le cul je ne nie pas les
faits je dis juste qu'ils sont exagérées
allait fermer
un peu partout on doit partout un job
aux abois pas un doigt pareil je
commence à la aaa
bon vent mais fais attention à toi une
pique au miel et c'est vite arrivé
et a
fallu qu d'avoir dû qu aux bonbons mais
fais attention à toi la conduite en état
d'ivresse est si vite arrivé n'abusez
pas au volant c'est un message de la
sécurité routière
merci yann pour cette intervention
l'actualité maintenant a confié multi
polarisé d'envergure internationale
serait dû se jouer à pile ou face à
genoux politique-là matin à prendre le
deuxième mcdo à 1 euro soit dû jouer à
pile ou face
match nul mathieu est un
challenge accepter aux appelants à 3
accepte un sorbet au [ __ ]
challenge sperme sur l'avesnois nous
sauver c'est pas ma faute je veux que je
te dis que mon gars j'ai commencé quand
j'avais sept heures et demie je vais
peut-être dû attendre mes 9 ans j'ai
commencé la bonne vieille branlette
quand j'avais 7 ans et demi
je ferai peut-être j'attendrai l'avant
j'ai gagné je le gagne donné j'ai
commencé les caf de sarcelles quand
j'avais 7 ans
mais ça que des taxes sur les
masturbations il avait pas grave mais on
est à 4 1 la you and you
une question d'hommes une réponse random
pour savoir qu'est ce qui gâche le sujet
de ma thèse de doctorat
a été étonnamment mal reçu plein de
choses il faut piocher un doigt dans le
cul il faut piocher
ce qu'est ce que je demande
le sujet de ma thèse de doctorat sortir
l'artillerie lourde a été étonnamment
mal aussi par le jury le sujet de ma
thèse de doctorat se torcher avec la
convention de genève a été étonnamment
mort reçues par les jurys citoyens
de nous bravo bravo je te propose le
point bonus là on choisit la question
est on est on choisit dans un des
énormes l'ipad et well ultra question
alors ce week end bah comme d'hab
vendredi soir samedi et donc dimanche
matin selanne et 900 serment je pense
que c'est moi parce que en fait moi je
raconte une histoire bon nenê on en a eu
face à se départager nos mêmes diplômes
qui a gagné c'était un record maman je
leur fais je le fais parce que moi elle
était vraiment très très drôle alors ce
week end comme d'hab on ne sera que tu
es mon âge bonjour la cia dans cette
vidéo n'hésitez pas à le dire dans leurs
diatribes qui selon moi gagner cette
question ultime ça vous a plu n'hésitez
pas aimé la vidéo sera peut-être
d'autres jeux comme ça avec keanu arrête
tu les influences mais non mais je vous
laisse affluent mais non ça va ça suffit
n'hésitez pas allez dans la chaîne de
yade si vous ne le connaissez pas et
vous avez intérêt à le connaître sinon
vous entendrez vie dans une prochaine
vidéo merci d'avoir gardé portez vous
bien sûr tout le monde pis
[Musique]